so we got two
rabis and a Muslim Imam here with usam
alikum how you guys doing
shalam you have a very please introduce
yourself we know Rabbi wse we want the
world to know that we representing our
religion declare that Palestine must be
free that Palestine has the right to be
free and that is unacceptable to occupy
Palestine till Zionism came about Jews
flourished as as distinctly religious
Jewish communities and they weren't
massacred on the contrary they went to
these Arab and Muslim lands to escape
persecution uh from the Crusades from
the Inquisition and from many other
trials and tribulations and the um and
even World War II uh the Arab and Muslim
lands opened their hearts opened their
lands and uh provided a safe haven and a
gracious Hospitality for the Jewish
people clearly they we we have different
religion and yet
uh we were we were accepted in these
Muslim and Arabs we believe in one God
and we were accepted we have different
ways of serving God but yet as I we were
respected and even the Muslim religion
requires of that of the uh the Muslim
people to to provide protection and
hospitality and they did uh carry that
out that's clear nobody could refute
this fact it's the legend Rabbi we here
Dr shik Dali
and your name is
Rabbi we have a in the Quran the whole
Surah chapter
Quran so you had a a story you wanted to
share with us please go ahead well um I
I tried the
best help of God uh move the mic his mic
closer my father had lived in in
Palestine but he he he didn't want to
stay there because to live under the
Zionist regime is very hard and it's he
didn't want to recognize the state of
Israel so every day it was very horrible
to go out protest and not to recognize
the
state so he left uh I don't know exactly
when which which year it was it was in
some in the
teres I'm sorry
the not
the um um it must have been
in in the like 70s in the
yeah so so he come here in the US it was
a story with what wise told but he's
better he wants he doesn't speak English
that well so he wants me to tell the
story of his father like I saw his
father's family has many thousands of
others and tens of thousands others
didn't want to be under the occupation
as he said under this state of Israel so
he left and came to America and I was
friendly with his father of blessed
memory he was
a scholar um and and a very activist
against the you also got to meet my
father
yeah go you give me long years I met the
many many special people distinguish
people so um his father of West memory
went in a demonstration as he went to
many often he demonstrated against the
state of Israel and once he he got a
growth on his neck but a big growth and
and and it had to be operated on they
couldn't get off he had to be operated
so but but be but before they scheduled
the this scheduled the operation for
maybe next day or two days later and in
the meantime there was a demonstration
so he went out to the demonstration now
the zionists what they do is they always
using tricks and different things they
used uh to to to beat the Jews but they
don't want it to be obvious what they're
doing to them so they have rubber um uh
trunions or whatever they're called and
in it has lead inside so they break the
bones inside but you from the outside it
doesn't you don't see the markings it
happens on so so while was demonstrating
one of these zionists from the Army or
police gave him a bang on the neck his
father's on his father's neck and
cracked open that that um that tumor or
whatever it was that was growing that uh
and and and he didn't need an operation
afterwards notg noty
wow see so that's why we really the you
know those people that special real you
that Allah
said few of them honest sincere and you
know they know the truth there's many
many such Jews I can tell you but the
world doesn't see and doesn't hear yes I
mean
exactly compared to compared to compared
to what we're seeing she's saying yeah
exactly so we have we're making history
here we have a razin a Palestinian and
not one but two rabbis here who are
making it clear that Zionism does not
represent Judaism and two Palestinians
these are two Palestinian Palestinian
wow wow wow two
Palestinians yeah yes so we we just
finished uh yeah you want to see
something go ahead a lot of times we're
going out for demonstrations a lot of
people of our community are saying me I
can't go out but you speak in out in our
name he's saying a lot people are afraid
to go out because they say we can't go
out but you speak in my name they tell
them you speak for me they're scared to
come out but they they're saying speak
in our names yes and they what do they
say this doesn't what represent us huh
the
same doose what they're doing you know
everything that the existence and
everything that emanates from this state
is uh evil is against God and so we
can't stop talking right now on this
second of Gaza it's just you know thank
you guys thank you so much and for those
who want to watch the full episode of
what we just did click right here thank
you guys peace peace s like